so let's look ahead to new year's we  have some details on the party downtown  on new year's eve  the fremont street experience says you  can go there downtown on new year's eve  but it certainly won't look like that of  course that's from previous years  earlier this month you'll remember the  area downtown didn't have permission  from the state to have a party  wristbands wristbands rather to get in  downtown  on the experience of 25 that can be  bought online or the downtown casinos  the gates will open at 6 but there will  be no live entertainment  with those celebrations there are going  to be closures  4th street and casino center boulevard  between carson and ogden  they will shut down at 9 00 new year's  eve morning  roads will reopen at 4 00 on new year's  day that'll be in the morning of course